avec nous donc AZ qui était à Washington
et Raphaël Jacob qui est ici avec nous
alors à Z rappelant les faits monsieur
Trump lui-même l'avait télégraphié je
serai accusé c'était pas arrivé la
semaine dernière et ça va arriver et ce
n'est pas à cause de l'insurrection du
11 janvier ce n'est pas à cause d'un
coup d'hectat c'est parce qu'il a son
équipe donnée un chèque à une femme pour
qu'elle thèse une relation
extra-conjugale expliquez-nous comment
ne plus arriver un accusation voilà donc
le Grand Jury 12 jurés ça prenait pour
inculper pour mettre en accusation
l'ancien président des États-Unis en
fait le fait qu'il est payé cette femme
là ça s'il y a rien d'illégal si vous
voulez mais c'est que quand il a fait sa
déclarations c'était déclaré comme frais
juridique et là où on parle de crime
c'est que ce financement là aurait aidé
sa campagne électorale en tout cas
n'aurait pas de nuit au fait qu'il
devienne président des États-Unis et
c'est là qui aurait eu crime et là le
grand jury c'est prononcé en dirant en
disant qui est assez de preuves pour
qu'il soit mis en examen c'est la
première fois que ça arrive dans notre
chambre Patrice vient de réagir il parle
de vraiment de persécution il dit que
c'est carrément un acte politique qu'on
veut l'empêcher de redevenir président
des États-Unis Alvin brag est traité de
personnes qui est financée par Josh
Strauss presque les démocrates s'en
prennent à lui et ça c'était très
visible de la part de temps donc il
réagit extrêmement fortement il a dit
que les les démocrates ont fait quelque
chose qui n'aurait jamais été qu'ils ont
ils n'auraient jamais osé faire dans le
passé mais que c'est vraiment le la
conclusion de toute cette chasse aux
sorcières qu'il a vécu depuis le début
de sa présidence Raphaël parlez moi du
du sérieux entre guillemets des
accusations et de l'impact que tout ça
peut avoir
pour ce qui est du sérieux des
accusations d'un point de vue
constitutionnel il faut toujours la
rappeler très clairement pour les gens
qui se posent encore la question se
statut là en aucun cas est-ce que ça
rend la candidature ou même l'éventuelle
présidente inéligible donc le fait
d'être inculqué et même à la limite dans
ce cas-ci probablement c'est ça qu'on
est dans un territoire inédit mais
probablement quand même le fait
éventuellement d'être reconnu coupable
ne le rendrait pas inéligible
très simplement très brièvement parce
qu'il y a rien dans la Constitution
américaine dans les articles qui
touchent les
éligibilité pardon pour les présidents
qui inclut par exemple le fait d'avoir
été inculpé même reconnu coupable d'un
crime donc la réponse simple tout simple
c'est ça maintenant pour ce qui est des
implications politiques électorales ça
l'aide ça l'aide dans le court terme et
je vais être catégorique là-dessus et
savoir l'air très contre intuitif ça
aussi pour bien les gens qui nous
entendent qui vont se dire comment
est-ce possible qu'elle fait d'être
accusé d'un crime au niveau fédéral peut
être bénéfique électoralement très
simplement là aussi parce que ça vient
fédérer une masse d'électeurs
républicain derrière lui donc dans le
plus court terme pour ce qui est des
primaires de 2024 ça vient non seulement
gonfler la base mais unifier une énorme
partie du parti républicain derrière lui
ça se statut c'est pas la conjoncture
c'est pas de l'hypothétique on l'a vu
après la percussion vers la gauche et on
le voit depuis les derniers jours tous
les sondages sont une année là-dessus
ils gagnent il gagne depuis qu'il a
annoncé qu'il allait être qu'il allait
être occupé maintenant ces choses-là je
vais revenir à ça après Azeb je vais
revenir en arrière le le Grand Jury de
l'État de New York là qui l'inculpe qui
l'accuse donc pour reprendre nos mots
notre vocabulaire à nous
est-ce que ceux qui disent les
républicains qui disent ils sont
politiques là est-ce qu'il y a une base
factuelle à ses accusations là du côté
républicain
non en fait ce que les républicains
disent c'est que si dans notre champ par
exemple s'il avait été inculpé en tout
cas mise en examen pour l'insurrection
du 6 janvier par exemple ou encore les
documents classés secret là qu'il aurait
ramené chez lui ou le fait d'avoir tenté
de renverser les élections en Georgie là
disons que pour même beaucoup de
démocrates il y aurait quelque chose là
dans l'affaire Tommy Daniel les gens
sont extrêmement divisés ils disent
franchement comment pouvez-vous mettre
un examen un ancien président pour une
histoire extraconjugale si vous voulez
donc beaucoup de républicains disent que
c'est véritablement un acte politique
pour l'empêcher de se présenter nous
quand on était à New York on a parlé à
ses partisans parce qu'il avait fait un
appel à tous ces partisans de venir à
New York parce que justement il allait
se faire arrêter c'était mardi dernier
il avait dit que mardi je me fais
arrêter et c'est partisans ce qu'ils
disent oui que c'est une chasse aux
sorcières que c'est une victime que
franchement cette affaire là n'est sans
importance qu'on devrait presque même
pas en parler si vous voulez donc et les
démocrates aussi sont divisées parce
qu'ils se disent bon s'il fallait bien
une affaire serait dû être soit
l'insurrection du 6 janvier soit le
renversement voilà mais c'est exactement
ce que les gens se posent et Raphaël
répondez-moi à ça là comme professeur là
comment se fait-il parce que l'homme a
quand même refusé le résultat électoral
démocratique dans son pays il y a il a
encouragé je pense que ça a été quand
même assez bien démontré par les faits
une insurrection en tout cas au capital
mais ça rien à voir là il est accusé il
est inculpé parce qu'il y a eu un chèque
de fait par un de ses avocats à une
femme pour qu'elle se taise pour ne pas
lui nuire à la campagne en quoi ces
criminels ça expliquez-moi ça leur
réexpliquez-moi ça d'abord
écoutez pas me sortir un chapeau de
professeur là c'est assez élémentaire en
principe dans une démocratie tous sont
égaux dans la loi et qui veulent un œuf
vole un bœuf donc que la loi soit d'une
énorme gravité ou non si dans le champ
plan frein en principe il devrait faire
face à la justice ça c'est vrai et dans
ce cas-ci si la trafiqué il a ordonné à
son légal dans ce cas c'est en 2016 le
trafiquer leur document interne pour
cacher ce qui était une dépense
possiblement électorale c'est possible
qu'il y a réellement crime qui a été
commis mais d'un point de vue politique
c'est vrai que franchement ça détonne
dans le contexte de tout mais en arrière
on stoppe les machines revenez en
arrière parce que je veux c'est
important de comprendre ça parce qu'on
fait comme c'est vraiment parce qu'il
aurait détourné des documents falsifier
des son équipe des documents pour cacher
ce qui dans le fond aurait dû aux yeux
de la justice être considéré comme une
dépense électorale exacte brièvement on
se replonge en 2016 on est à la toute
fin de la campagne entre lui et Madame
Clinton et il essaye de réussit à
acheter le silence temporairement on
s'entend de stormydanium en se disant ça
va m'aider la littéralement que ce
scandale là ce nouveau scandale là ne
sort pas publiquement sur moi et ma
candidature
et parce que ça a pas été déclaré en
fait parce qu'on aurait possiblement
essayé de cacher cette dépense
électorale là il y aurait fraude
là-dedans parce que toute dépense
électorale semblable à ça doit être
déclaré ce qu'on allait
demander à son équipe légale de le
cacher très bien on a les on a une
fondation solide pour tout le monde
est-ce comment les républicains plus
modérés vont réagir comment deux
centimes vont réagir comment est-ce
qu'il va avoir est-ce que ça va avoir
les faits comme disait Raphaël d'un
ralliement d'après vous là puis ça va
même aider monsieur Trump comme le
disait Raphaël les sondages le lundi
quand même là dans notre chambre et
maintenant en avance la toute cette
affaire est en train de mousser sa
popularité si vous voulez rendre de
synthétise commençait à devenir
populaire mais là dans notre chambre le
dépasse de plusieurs points presque de
20 points dans les derniers sondages
donc en fait c'est vraiment entraîne en
train de l'aider cette histoire de de
stormy Daniels et pour les républicains
évidemment il se retrouve avec dans
notre chambre qui est évidemment c'est
un fardeau un peu embarrassant parce
qu'il après vraiment gagner la primaire
là et se présenter comme candidat des
républicains loin de sentis est en train
de chuter si vous voulez dans les
sondages c'était celui qui était le plus
si vous voulez qu'il pouvait pas
remplacer de chambre mais qui était le
plus populaire parmi les candidats à la
présidence puis il est même pas encore
candidat là il y a juste là qui
s'est porté officiellement candidate à
la présidence donc pour les républicains
ils sont divisés en tout cas peu
critique chambre pour le moment ok
rapidement des deux côtés rapidement des
deux côtés Raphaël commence par vous
mais non je commence par avec Azeb on
s'attend à quoi dans les prochaines
heures bon là Monsieur Trump a réagi dit
c'est tout ça est un cirque il ira à New
York quand il ira à New York est-ce
qu'il sera photographié est-ce qu'il va
aller les prises d'empreintes à quoi là
comme tout le monde comme le disait
l'avocat de stormy Daniels voilà
personne est au-dessus des lois il a
toujours la présomption d'innocence ils
vont prendre sa photo prendre ses
empreintes digitales mais on connaît le
personnage là il va avertir tous ces
partisans pour qu'ils viennent le
soutenir ça jusqu'à être un cirque
médiatique là puisque c'est historique
quand même la première fois qu'un
président est mise en accusation au
criminel la scène s'est jamais vu dans
l'histoire des États-Unis donc c'est
gros c'est un candidat aussi et puis le
fait qu'ils disent que voilà on essaye
de l'empêcher en fait de devenir
candidat à la présidence on essaye
vraiment voilà c'est une chasse aux
sorcières certainement qui va avoir
énormément de partisans qui vont être là
mais là ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est que ces avocats sont en train de
négocier comment tout ceci va se passer
parce qu'il y a aussi des questions de
sécurité là il faudra que Trump ait une
sécurité autour de lui le protéger et ça
le procureur de Noël c'est vraiment à
garantissant on croyait qu'on allait
avoir un petit vendredi peut-être
Raphaël merci on va se reparler demain
on va se reparler le temps qu'il le
faudra